When we were browsing the Christmas section at the store last night,
my toddlers freaked out when they saw candy canes
and begged me to get some.
I told them I would make them some in the morning and they agreed.
Started by combining some sugar,
corn syrup and water and letting that heat up to 300 degrees.
Once it hit 300 I divided it in half to my white section.
I just added some mint extract and began folding it in,
and when it wasn't too hot to handle
I began stretching it out until I couldn't do it anymore.
The other half of my sugar mixture
I added some cherry extract and some red colour
and repeated the same steps I did with the white candy.
Started by folding it into each other and then stretching it out.
Once I couldn't stretch it anymore,
I began molding the two colours together,
slowly twisting it around each other to make classic candy cane swirl.
Once I was satisfied with the length,
I cut it, twisted it,
and made sure to get that signature hug.
At this point
my kids wouldn't wait any longer and needed to try them immediately.